the governor says he's only experiencing
mild head congestion his recovery comes
as many nevadans worry about a possible
second shutdown
8 news now reporter sally jeremiah spoke
to unlv economy professors
who predict what another shutdown could
mean to southern nevada
sally brian after our first shutdown
in march many fear the same thing could
happen all
over again but what would that mean for
our jobs
and our economy now if it were to happen
experts say it could take
years to recover brian levis is the
assistant professor for the unlv school
of public health
he says as cases increase it is
extremely concerning and there's a lot
of uncertainty
just last week governor syslak urged
nevadans to stay at home as much as
possible
to curb the numbers with that news there
is a lot of concern about what is next
lavis tells me he does not see a
shutdown again due to the economic
consequences we are still dealing with
right now so it doesn't mean shutting
down the whole state
all at once i think it means there would
probably be some interim steps in there
just to reduce the amount of people that
are around other people
well covet hasn't gone away lavis says
we have an advantage because we
understand it better now
and know that there are steps to take to
stop the transmission
if we were to shut down again lavis
believes the first things that will
close would be the last things that have
opened up
such things like bars and restaurants
reporting live near the strip sally
jaramillo 8 news now
sally thank you